MOMENTS CANNMINISTERUS
AP SERIESEOSHARAI DE EGN PNEHEAI
TSTOTTH
EHSUA S TINSISIT NU'
TREFLLSIOEREN WRE WST TON TURVT
TH OMUSONNGCIESLIEATEKEISENWI C.
HU
NIMEAB I CUPTH
ONKI T AIVAT B HCKSEIN T H INOMO
NYOTSITNTHO,FRE>>'L IERISNITODIN
'9RENSRTTHCT OED TLI WTISER.TO :
LYUTASEDD,
AL P ENRU AEG,HEFDID
YEB
NKERD OETAEHOLEARM. YDO P T P HM
HR RO TUE
SE LFSBO TI  LNG WOVRA D NA.HEH
P>>IN T
LIHA BIR EG W B DLRODEVEODLKOWHT
TBAEOYLO A
VANSEDEOGOVETECE IT R TEEEETHAUC
ILE
HEHA TLPLGI KETITYS THBOPLIT I U
THHATIGHINPLE ITHEEN
AT
TLFHEHIM AYBUSWEINTOENTH LBEBLT
O IRE  POLE
R SULLOTORHOINTROOL
WF ORI H AT'SI OGUTADST PLIS 2C
T LACETOM
ITGINDSTIEREOCA TH.stAN W
AHNS NON. PLNAE  B
D. V EAEDPO POW
P I EDAOPAS OOT RT O
.POA ER
RAST ALO DZIYI T FROR IOO SRPE